Libertarians just want to take care of themselves
and not take care of other people.
You must hate the poor you must love the rich.
You must be a pacifist.
They're different from what you are.
I want everybody to die from tainted liquor
or from food poisoning.
For Reason I'm Justin Monticello, I'm here
in New Hampshire for PorcFest
or the Porcupine Freedom Festival put on by
the free state project.
It's an annual week long gathering of liberty
minded individuals from anarchists to libertarians.
I'm here to ask people what's one thing you're
tired of hearing
when you tell other people your political
beliefs?
Sometimes people say things like 'oh anarchists
are all violent.
Without government warlords would take over
society.
It bothers me because with government warlords
have already taken over society.
My mom she pretty much just asks
'why are you a libertarian? we're supposed
to be Democrats.'
They're like 'normally black people aren't
libertarians.'
But I'm like 'nah some people are just way
different than others.
Being a Democrat it's kind of a trap you know?
They tell you one thing and then do something
else.
I really dislike when people say 'well Venezuela
didn't fall because it wasn't real socialism.'
You know, marijuana's evil.
How will people build public roads without
government.
The taxes that you pay as a business are the
price that you pay to be a part of a civilized society.
I grew up in the north of Mexico, my parents
are cattle ranchers
and no one maintained the road, no government
did.
The local ranchers got together, decided to
pool their funds to hire a tractor to go pave the road.
So who will build the roads?
Well I've already answered that question in
my own lifetime.
Definitely I'm transitioning into a crypto
based company.
I'm really tired of hearing all of people's
fear excuses.
People that say that the bailouts that we
did, you know, that these banks were too big to fail.
The rich don't pay for this stuff, you know,
it's regular people.
You know the people that can basically least
afford it.
I shouldn't object to paying 26 thousand dollars
a year in taxes to run a small restaurant
so that I can have employees that can barely
read.
What I'm most tired of hearing is that I don't
care about the environment, charity
just because I don't want government doing
anything about it.
Small changes in the amount of decentralization
or centralization changes how happy our society is,
how healthy our children are, how long you'll
live, that sort of thing.
I actually care more than the person who's
not willing to question
how they go about accomplishing those goals.
I'd say I'm tired of maybe a lack of openness?
You know, what are your philosophies rather
than your labels.
I know the only thing that the universe really
cares about is how we treat each other.
Using coercive government, just, it's time
to move beyond that.
There's much less harmful, much more efficient
ways of doing that.
I mean I like being free.